well that ceasefire wasn't something
that was agreed on it was declared
unilaterally by
the government of ethiopia and declared
very much a moment when they seem to be
on the back
foot the regional capital of mckelley
had been taken that was on monday night
by the tplf fighters and we've heard
since then just uh in in the last 24
hours that the tplf
have taken other small towns aksum
shiree
but it's hard to find out exactly what's
going on across the region because
the phones are cut off but the tplf
definitely feel that they've they've got
more work to do they're they're the
statements they've been making that
very much say that they intend to keep
fighting they feel that they've lost
territory not just to
ethiopian government soldiers but also
eritrean soldiers who've been involved
in the conflict coming from the north
and also members of militia from
the amara region of ethiopia have been
coming from the south
for months the humanitarians have been
have been saying that complaining
there's a lack of access
to reach people that un have said
recently there are hundreds of thousands
of people on the verge
of famine or some of them uh already
experiencing famine and this conflict's
been characterized by
abuses of civilians widespread reports
of sexual violence
massacres of civilians looting of
livestock burning of crops and these are
things in an area where most people are
subsistence farmers